also wenn die einzige taktik ist oder
ist gewalt wir machen ein
auslandseinsatz man jetzt ja jetzt
bleiben wir da wir bleiben so lange wie
möglich jetzt gehen wir wieder weg und
wir richten da geht es direkt weiter und
wieder werden alle unterdrückt dann ist
es einfach anscheinend nicht die taktik
die am besten funktioniert
[Musik]
ich beginne direkt mit der ersten frage
von 13 fragen sollte die bundeswehr
weiter im ausland eingesetzt werden wenn
ihr sagt ja auf jeden fall müssen
einsätze der bundeswehr im ausland
weiter stattfinden dann geht er jetzt
aus grünefeld und wenn ihr sagt nein wir
müssen irgendwie wege finden wie wir das
in zukunft verhindern können dann geht
ihr bitte auch skibbe fällt
[Musik]
wenn soldaten der deutschen bundeswehr
ins ausland geschickt werden dann geht
es oft darum terrorregime und zu
bekämpfen und die bevölkerung vor ort
sowie hilfsorganisationen zu schützen
nachdem die taliban vor kurzem nach
einem 20 jährigen einsatz die macht in
afghanistan zurück erobert haben stellt
sich jetzt die frage war alles umsonst
und wie viel sinn machen solche
auslandseinsätze der nato es wirklich
und wenn wir sie noch brauchen welche
ziele sollten sie in zukunft verfolgen
meine gäste sind sich uneins die einen
sagen es geht nicht ohne
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr und die
anderen wiederum sind sich sicher sie
müssen endlich ein ende haben beide
seiten ringen um kompromisse und
vielleicht am ende ja sogar um eine
lösung die erste frage geht jetzt aber
erstmal an euch auf welcher seite des
spielfeldes würdet ihr stehen gelb oder
grün schreibt mir gerne in den
kommentaren ab jetzt wenn ihr der
anderen seite in einem argument zustimmt
dann könnt ihr einfach einen schritt auf
die andere seite zu gehen und falls euch
etwas aufregt und ihr das irgendwie
deutlich machen wollt mit eurer bewegung
dann geht er einen schritt zurück das
könnt ihr gerne fließend in eure
bewegungen während der diskussion auch
während andere person reden mit
einbringen ich freue mich sehr auf die
diskussion mit euch und beginnen direkt
mit der zweiten frage von 13 fragen
andreas die geht an dich du bist
insgesamt sieben mal in afghanistan im
einsatz gewesen du musst es dort mit
ansehen wie kamerad innen von dir
gefallen sind wie afghanische
zivilistinnen dir ans herz gewachsen
sind wie die getötet wurden würdest du
denn sagen dass du den persönlich den
einsatz in afghanistan bereits
ich habe mich natürlich gerade mit den
bildern aus august sehr stark daran
zurück was ich erlebt habe und ich
versuche viel darüber zu sprechen über
diese dinge die ich gesehen habe
aufzuklären und
ich bereue den einsatz in afghanistan
auf keinen fall und ich würde wieder in
den einsatz gehen nach afghanistan
weil ich finde wir haben viele gute
dinge eben auch erreicht wir haben für
einen gewissen zeitraum für eine
stabilität gesorgt und für sicherheit
dass menschen und gerade eben frauen und
kinder auch zur schule gehen konnten
dass sie eine regelmäßige bildung
erfahren weil nur über bildung erreiche
ich die menschen auch auslandseinsätze
für dich total wichtig können die
menschen nur mit der militärischen
präsenz auch vor ort vernünftig
erreichen und eben humanitäre zwecke
auch nur sichern wenn wir eben militär
mit robust mitteln auf rot haben also
wenn du eine zeit zurückreisen könnte es
dann würde es wieder tun ja dann an euch
die seit die gelbe seite des feldes ihr
seid auf der seite gegen die
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr
was machen die worte von andreas mit
euch geht er einen schritt auf ihn zu
ich habe zwischen ich mir überlegt ob
ich einen schritt zurückgehen auch wenn
das natürlich nicht so weit geht gar
nicht unbedingt weil ich glaube dass
viele dinge dort absolut richtig sind
wie gesagt worden sind ich finde den
punkt allerdings relativ spannend zu
sagen ich würde auch jetzt noch mal in
den einsatz gehen nach afghanistan ich
glaube dass
auch natürlich bestimmte erfolge
sicherlich erzielt werden können in
unterschiedlichen einsätzen und mit
unterschiedlichen mitteln aber
grundsätzlich stellt sich ja immer noch
die frage wenn wir sowieso warum uns das
ganze angucken was dann letzten endes
erreicht worden ist meiner meinung nach
die bundeswehr nicht weiter im ausland
eingesetzt werden weil es tatsächlich
jetzt der zeitpunkt ist das zivile
organisationen zivile initiativen aber
auch zivilgesellschaft gestärkt werden
mussten ich finde ein argument zu sagen
dass frauen für ein paar jahre zur
schule gehen konnten wenn es für mich
kein solides argument weil ich der
meinung bin dass man eventuell mit
anderen möglichkeiten mit anderen
lösungen deutlich bessere ergebnisse
hätte erzielen können moritz michael
ihren bleibt auch stehen ich glaube also
ich meine bewegung wäre gewesen dass ich
denke ja ich glaube ich sofort dass du
da gewesen bist dass es in dem moment
dass du dass du das gefühl hast da
irgendwas du hast was gutes erreicht und
dass das leute für ein paar jahre lang
in sicherheit waren und das finde ich
super gut und vorgedacht ja aber jetzt
christel wieder hier und alle sind
wieder hier meiner meinung nach soll die
bundeswehr nicht weiter im ausland
eingesetzt werden weil ein land das den
weltkrieg angefangen hat nicht versuchen
sollte gegen etwas mit waffen gefallen
zu lösen insgesamt denke ich
wahrscheinlich hätte man das was wir
erreicht hat in afghanistan als truppe
meiner meinung nach auch
nicht sagen anders hätte erreichen
können aber die frage nach einer ist er
aber was passt jetzt wert wenn man das
mist an was ist ein gewalt passiert
markt mit weiter auf geantwortet was das
ergebnis kann man dieses ergebnis ich
auch irgendwie anders erreichen andreas
du nicht was sagst du dazu erstmal
vielen dank für das was du gesagt hast
und natürlich ich bin durchaus dafür
nach dem sprichwort frieden schaffen
ohne waffen wie ich der erste der sofort
ja sagt dann also ich bin
durchaus gewillt auch zuzuhören und
meine argumente zu ändern was sehen die
drei vier möglichkeiten
in afghanistan oder eben im
auslandseinsatz speziell zu erreichen
mit anderen als militärischen mitteln
zahlen und wie kann man gesagt dass man
kann die ergebnisse anders erreichen und
wie kann man die ergebnisse ohne waffen
anders erreichen wie kann kann man sich
gegen taliban und waffen kämpfen ich bin
nicht so naiv zu sagen es gibt keinen
konflikt irgendwann menschen nicht mit
waffen beschützen sollte ich bin nicht
der meinung dass deutschland als land
als mb das machen sollte es gibt so
etwas wie un friedenstruppen dafür
müsste man die un warum bauen ich
verstehe den punkt dass man sagt man
möchte die bevölkerung mit waffen
schützen mit waffengewalt gegen waffen
alles was danach passiert ist stehen
geblieben bei er jetzt bleiben wir hier
mit den waffen so lange wir können und
so weit wir das nicht mehr können gehen
wir wieder weg und der schritt fehlte
als bundeswehr zu dem punkt ob es
frieden ohne waffen geben kann da
sprechen wir später auf jeden fall auch
noch ausführlich darüber hat er die
luftbrücke kabul ist eine
zivilgesellschaftliche initiative die
mit charterflügen die evakuierung von
orts kräften und schutzbedürftigen aus
afghanistan unterstützt hat und die
bundeswehr die es ja auch darum solche
hilfsorganisationen zu schützen sie soll
ihr euch eigentlich quasi den rücken
frei machen würdest du sagen dass das
funktioniert hat was wir vor allem
gesehen haben ist einerseits ein extrem
schneller rückzug der deutschen truppen
und was wir aber auf gesehen haben ist
das eine politische agenda
selbstverständlich hinter genau diesen
evakuierungsmaßnahmen steht und der
unwille des deutschen staates und da
nehme ich jeden bundeswehrsoldaten mit
raus weil darüber kann ich nicht
urteilen ich kann nicht urteilen darüber
ob du noch mehr menschen hätten es immer
probieren wollte aber der deutsche staat
wollte nicht und das ist das problem
meiner meinung nach an der bundeswehr
dass wir uns immer wieder konfrontiert
sehen mit den staatlichen interessen und
ein soldat oder eine soldatin kann noch
so gute ansichten haben und noch so das
gute wollen letzten endes unterliegt es
dann aber natürlich eben immer noch dem
staat was dort gemacht wird und der
staat hat bei der evakuierung in
afghanistan ganz klar gesagt möglichst
wenig afghaninnen nach deutschland das
das klingt jetzt aber danach als wärst
du dafür dass die bundeswehr da ist aber
irgendwie eine andere stelle des staates
hat keine gute arbeit gemacht aber die
bundeswehr schon und dann sollte die
bundeswehr weiter in einsätzen seien im
ausland es ist wichtig dass sich die wir
weiterhin im ausland engagiert weil
deutschland sehr lange davon profitiert
hat dass andere staaten sich militärisch
eingesetzt haben für eine friedliche
ordnung diese aufrechtzuerhalten damit
deutschland sich demokratisch und
wirtschaftlich entwickeln kann und
deutschland sollte jetzt auch seiner
eigenen verantwortung nachkommen und
sich in internationalen verbänden mit
anderen anderenorts dafür einsetzen dass
auch dort demokratie menschenrechte und
frieden zu haben kommen gesichert werden
wir haben uns die evakuierung angucken
natürlich hat das militärische kräfte
gebraucht wer hätte den flughafen
schützen sollen in dem fall wenn wir uns
da historische angucken was bereits
passiert ist bin ich auch bereit zu
sagen okay dann hätte es noch mehr
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz
hätte geben müssen bei den deutschen
evakuierungen sarah du bist auch ein
schritt auf materie zugegangen warum
weil mein tier hat gesagt sie wollten
gerne menschen helfen wird mehr menschen
evakuieren lassen nach deutschland
bringen und leider die konnten das nicht
weil deutlich wurde dass gesagt und ich
finde halt in der situation ist sehr
wichtig dass die menschen dass wir die
menschen schützen und helfen und nach
deutschland oder in eine sichere platz
zu bringen ist es sehr wichtig dass die
bundeswehr sich weiterhin in afghanistan
engagiert weil es wegen der
machtübernahme von taliban in der ganzen
situation sehr schlecht geworden und
alle wünschen sich
deutschland und andere länder den hilfen
andreas ist auch ein schritt auf uns
zugegangen
ja weil ich die aktion super toll finde
dass du
unterstützt hast eben die ortskräfte
auch noch zu retten mit engagement und
wenn ich könnte würde ich auch verlangen
dass die bundeswehr weiter engagement
zeigt um eben noch mehr menschen zu
retten allein für diese evakuierungs
mission und glaubt mir das eben der
große hat der soldaten die vor ort waren
die werden nicht raus gezogen wenn das
nicht der befehl gewesen wäre und der
politische wille selbstverständlich
nicht ich würde auch wenn sich der kurs
zwischen halten darf sagen also deine
motive scheinen ja sehr ehrenwert zu
sein aber der auftrag den die
bundesregierung ursprünglich gegeben hat
der auch nur folgen einige level war das
wird ja heute auch oft vergessen ist ein
ganz anderer und annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat ja gerade auch noch
gesagt ja einsatz war erfolgreich gab
lange keine richtigen anschläge in
deutschland und so weiter ich glaube
nicht dass ernsthaft von der politik die
afghaninnen und afghanen so sehr im
fokus waren sondern es ging darum quasi
deutschland abzusichern was man finde
ich auch bezweifeln kann weil trotzdem
die gefahr islamistischen terrors in
deutschland durch auslandseinsätze
gestiegen ist gewalt ist keine lösung
das sehen wir dass gerade in afghanistan
aber es sind wir auch in anderen
konflikten das militär nachhaltig keinen
frieden bringen kann versteckte dauernd
anbrechen auch immer wieder auf und
deswegen sind wir grundsätzlich gegen
militär und für eine weltweite abrüstung
ich möchte gern noch mal zu der frage
zurückkommen ab wann ist denn so einen
auslandseinsatz gerade jetzt im fall von
afghanistan erfolgreich und wann nicht
was sind unsere ziele sarah du kommst
aus afghanistan deine mutter wurde
früher politisch verfolgt weil sie sich
für frauenrechte und für das recht auf
bildung eingesetzt hat und durch den
nato einsatz hat sich wie ihr alle auch
schon angesprochen habe für viele
menschen in afghanistan vor allem auch
für frauen natürlich das leben für 20
jahre sehr stark verbessert jetzt ist
die taliban aber wieder an der macht wie
schätzt du das persönlich ein sala
würdest du sagen dass der einsatz
umsonst war
ich denke der einsatz war nicht umsonst
der einsatz hatte sehr gute und positive
auswirkungen besonders für frauen und
auch ich sehe persönlich für mich es hat
sehr gute positive auswirkungen
95 alles hier geboren war taliban sind
gekommen nach afghanistan und ich durfte
nicht zur schule gehen nicht komplett
verschwunden und hier wurde das recht
auf bildung verboten und als nato und
vereinte nationen und ausland einsetzt
im jahr 2000 gekommen war dürfte ich
wieder an der schule gehen mich
weiterbilden weiterentwickeln und ich
denke das war eine sehr gute positive
sache und es ist sehr gut wenn ausland
sei ein setzte sich weiter so macht und
weiterhin afghanistan sich engagiert
moritz würdest du denn sarah in dem
punkt zustimmen dass wir den erfolg von
solchen einsätzen vielleicht nicht nur
daran messen sollten wie viele ziele wir
dann tatsächlich auch erreicht haben
sondern vielleicht auch für wie viele
menschen wir das leben in diesen 20
jahren verbessert haben
ja ich natürlich eben einzelnen menschen
die man helfen kann das ist ein ziel das
man haben sollte und ich weiß dass das
man so etwas in der armee braucht um
bestimmte ziele durchzusetzen wie zum
beispiel menschen die sie nie mehr davor
fürchten müssen dass bewaffnete gruppen
das dorf überfallen das ist keine frage
für mich ist aber die frage wenn man das
koppelt an drei oder vier nationen die
sagen wir machen das und irgendwann sagt
die nation ich glaube die bisher keinen
bock mehr dann ziehen wir uns raus dann
ist das ja eines der probleme wenn die
ganze welt als un sagt wir sind da um
den frieden zu schützen dann kann der
deutschen bundeswehr humanitär
eingreifen und sagen übrigens sind wir
wir sind zwar die welt aber wir sind
eine humanitäre einheitlich die versucht
euch zu helfen ohne waffengewalt andreas
und sagen ihr seid beide einen schritt
zurückgegangen also wenn die un die un
in einem einsatz ist dann ist es ja auch
so dass da die bundeswehr beteiligt ist
es da beispielsweise kommando funktionen
der bundeswehr sind das die fähigkeiten
der bundeswehr auf verschiedenen der
wills einbezogen werden weil das ist
einfach teil davon aber gleichzeitig ist
es auch so dass es situationen gibt wo
eben dieses ziel un-mandat wo sich
sozusagen die ganze welt
nicht oder zumindest irgendwie die
vetomächte im un sicherheitsrat nicht
nein sagen das lässt sich halt nicht
immer erreichen wir haben auch so ein
beispiel wie syrien zum beispiel wo
chemiewaffen angriffe gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
gefahren wurden die massiv stärkere
auswirkungen auch auf frauen und mädchen
hatten dass es auch nachgewiesen und da
weiß eben eine situation wo russland als
schutzmacht gesagt hat wir gucken da
einfach zu und deswegen ist es ist es so
dass ich auch immer sagen würde der
idealfall ist nur ein mandat ist eine un
mission ist ein blauhelm mission sowie
das auch vielerorts aktuell der fall ist
ein text ja ich weiß das ist natürlich
alles vollkommen korrekt ja also ich
meine wenn wir uns natürlich den ganzen
apparat angucken ich frag mich schon ob
wir über die un reden oder über die
bundeswehr ich glaube die sind sehr
unterschiedliche sachen und
selbstverständlich haben wir in beiden
aber genau das gleiche problem haben
staatliche interessen und wir haben auch
eine staatliche agenda die es im
un-sicherheitsrat umso präsenter wie
noch zuvor so wir haben dort starten die
entscheidung und vetorechte haben die
eben tatsächlich natürlich
selbstverständlich eigene interessen
haben das gleiche kann mir aber auch ins
kleine bringen können dann noch mal
wieder zurück zur bundeswehr kommen dass
ich glaube also du hast vorhin gesagt
die bundeswehr sollen einerseits wieder
zurück nach afghanistan und das ziel
sollte sein menschen zu evakuieren würde
ich direkt dazu dir aufs grünefeld bild
also ich finde es gibt auch andere
lösungen aber wenn das tatsächlich dann
am ende das resultat dieses einsatzes
wäre können wird heute abend noch
kaffeetrinken auf dem grünfeld aber das
problem ist das widerspricht sich und da
beißt sich nämlich die katze total im
schwanz die bundeswehr kann eben nicht
das was du gesagt hast allein ständig
machen die bundeswehr kann ich sagen so
wir möchten jetzt hier zurück in den
einsatz nach afghanistan wir möchten
unsere evakuierungsmaßnahmen fortführen
weil immer wieder die staatliche agenda
auf dem spiel steht und wir müssen
einfach langsam lernen dass letzten
endes genau solche krisen momente
niemals los gelöst werden können von
staatlichen interessen und deswegen bin
ich zum beispiel der meinung dass ich
glaube dass man beispielsweise die die
unterstützung von zivilen initiativen
die eben nicht unbedingt staatlich sind
dass man die vorantreiben kann aber auch
mit hilfe des staates der darf sich
nämlich natürlich nicht aus der
verantwortung ziehen im beirat würdest
du dann sagen dass es diese staatlichen
interessen gar nicht gibt doch sache auf
jeden fall da sind gewisse dinge drin
trotzdem als ich meine was afghanistan
angeht also ich meine nine eleven ist
passiert so die usa haben die
entscheidung getroffen
deshalb nach afghanistan zu gehen das
war ein nato bündnisfall deutschland hat
sich daraufhin auf diesen terroranschlag
der passiert ist und diese dieser
aufforderung der usa dem angeschlossen
da würde ich jetzt nicht unterstellen
dass deutschland das gemacht hat weil es
irgendwas aus noch ganz ohne ausholen
wollte aber da sind wir uns vielleicht
uneins aber auch was das auf jeden fall
hindeutet ist eben genau die frage und
deshalb sind wir auch heute hier das ist
super wichtig ist darüber mehr zu
sprechen weil es ist nun mal so und es
stimmt dass leute in deutschland oft
nicht wissen warum ist denn die
bundeswehr einmal wie zum beispiel und
das ist es ist super wichtig dass man
darüber dass herbert redet was wäre dann
deine meinung warum sie in mali ist zum
beispiel in mali war ein ähnlicher fall
mit terroranschlägen in frankreich und
da die französische armee und der
bündnisfall und jetzt gibt es ja
inzwischen auch eine un-mission in mali
es gibt da ja verschiedene verschiedene
missionen multinationale unter anderem
auch un und und da ist es jetzt einfach
so das ist ja das beruf für ihr vorhin
auch war un sicherheitsresolution gibt
wo sich einfach deutschland daran eben
beteiligt dort es gibt auch den
politischen friedensprozess ein
friedensabkommen das zu sichern und dazu
versuchen das eben nicht bewaffnete
gruppen in die dörfer überfallen und so
weiter das anders was vorhin gefallen
ist da ist deutschland beteiligt es gibt
wiederum es gibt wiederum einsätze in
mali an dem deutschland nicht beteiligt
ist wo frankreich stärker offensiv
terrorismus bekämpft und wo die
bundeswehr oder oder die politik in
deutschland gesagt hätten die da machen
wir nicht mit aber wir machen damit und
und da gibt es ja schon diese das
differenzieren da habt jetzt mal hier
angesprochen wenn jetzt über afghanistan
gesprochen aber lasst uns mal kurz für
moment grundsätzlich raussuchen und das
thema von außen betrachten also
grundsätzlich auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr
denn du sara du forscht seit langer zeit
zum thema außen und sicherheitspolitik
was würdest du denn sagen ab wann ist so
ein bundeswehreinsatz erfolgreich gibt
es da schon beispiele zu nennen könntest
ja es gibt situationen wie
beispielsweise
massen verbrechen in srebrenica und da
eine intervention die damals auch nicht
durch den un-sicherheitsrat mandatiert
war das ist natürlich auch eine
situation die sich niemand wünscht wo
aber vor ort einfach massiv leute
umgebracht werden der kampagne gegen
bestimmte minderheiten
bevölkerungsgruppen stattfindet und in
so einer situation wird dann
waffengewalt angewendet um zu versuchen
das zu stoppen und das wäre der fall in
situationen wo eben politische
verhandlungen wo friedensverhandlungen
gar nicht möglich sind
wie das ja leider häufig passiert und
dann erstmal eine notwendigkeit ist
damit die tierischen offensiver was
entgegenzusetzen
um sozusagen in der stadt situation
herbeizuführen und die frage ist dann
natürlich wie geht es danach weiter und
da würde ich niemals sagen afghanistan
sollte das modell sein und so was sollte
auf jeden fall wieder passieren lasst
uns mal bei dem thema erfolg in
anführungszeichen bleiben michael du
bist am weitesten hinten vom feld von
allen du willst nämlich trotz diesen
einzelnen erfolgen die sarah zum
beispiel gerade aufgezählt hat nicht nur
auslandseinsätze sondern gleich die
ganze bundeswehr abschaffung wachstum
erklären warum nicht nur die bundeswehr
sondern militär weltweit oder auch mit
natürlich terrorgruppen und so war es
weil wir oder einer weise dass endlich
auch natürlich der überzeugung sind dass
es ein mensch als ziel sein muss
natürlich dass es keine gewalt mehr gibt
kein militär mehr gibt ist natürlich
eine utopie ist weiß ich das werde ich
nicht mehr erleben aber ich denke schon
dass man daran arbeiten muss und ich
sehe gerade oder seit vielen jahren das
ist natürlich total in eine andere
richtung geht er es wird wieder massiv
aufgerüstet und ja es werden wieder
militäreinsätze geführt von deutschland
aus wird die wir wieder als normalität
verkauft und meiner meinung nach werden
halt auch nicht alle mittel die man
sonst zur verfügung hätte um auch
außenpolitisch zu wirken werden halt
nicht ausgeschöpft jetzt gerade chinas
ja auch so als ob irgendwelche
massenmorde so aus dem nichts passieren
aber das hat ja alles langen ursprung
und da könnte man ja auch zum beispiel
präventiv reagieren deutschland das
immer noch unter den top 5 der
rüstungsexporteure der welt zum beispiel
oder natürlich auch so was wie grenzen
öffnen um leute zu schützen und so war's
oder natürlich auch das fiel mir auf
diplomatie gesetzt wie ihr ziviler
friedensdienst und solche sachen also
ich finde
das ist noch längst nicht ausgeschöpft
und deswegen werde ich erstmal froh wenn
man das aus schaffen würde und erstmal
weniger militärisch reagieren würde
erstmal die bundeswehr wieder nach
deutschland holt und dann natürlich auch
international verhandelt internationale
verträge schließt zur abrüstung andreas
will dass du michael da zustimmen also
ich glaube das passieren schuldige den
begriff blauäugig zu glauben dass wenn
wir kein militär haben gibt es keine
gewalt mehr das wäre wünschenswert ganz
klar ohne gewalt würden wir glaube ich
auf dieser welt viel besser leben und
die anderen dinge die du angesprochen
hast natürlich auch aber ich glaube
nicht dass wir das militär abschaffen
dass es keine gewalt mehr gebe weil es
gibt immer gruppen die ihre interessen
durchsetzen wollen sei es ethnische
gruppen oder religiöse gruppen die
einfach interessen haben die mit anderen
gruppen wieder nicht über eingehen und
da ist die frage wie emc brienzer viele
sich seine konflikte auf das sind
menschen getötet worden eben oder
schrecklichste art und weise ich habe
auf bildern die massengräber gesehen und
leute die dabei waren von der un und
zuschauen mussten die leute ab gemetzelt
werden die sind bis heute noch tiefs
traumatisiert und ja es wäre
wünschenswert dass wenn man dann das die
logische folge wäre ich hoffe militär ab
und es gibt dann keine gewalt manager
aber auch alle gruppen müssen natürlich
irgendwie dafür gewonnen werden generell
abschlüssen ich weiß das ist super
schwierig aber man darf immer nicht nur
aus dieser deutschen sicht sehen sondern
auch das russische militär wird
abgeschafft zum beispiel noch weiter und
wir müssen waffen vernichten zum
beispiel und da auch abrüsten und ich
weiß das wird sich natürlich erstmal
auch weiter natürlich gewalt geben und
so was und das polizeikräfte und so was
man die haben auch waffen und so was er
isst man nur zivile sache sowas ist ein
komplizierter prozess schon sagt ich
werde nicht erleben aber ich finde da
müsste man zumindest mal anfangen soll
aber alle wollen keine waffen keine
krieg alle verschieden aber dass er
seinen traum ohne waffen ohne militär
der welt zu schützen alle wollen das
aber das geld hab halt nicht ich glaube
es funktioniert aber wir müssen halt
mehr dafür tun also ich weiß es klingt
mega naiv wenn man sagt ich weiß es
klingt wie ein traum wenn man sagt ja
aber mit weniger waffen gibt es ja
vielleicht auch weniger tote für mich
klingt es genauso naiv zu sagen oder es
gewalt vielleicht anbauen wollen wir mit
gewalt und dann am ende ist ja
vielleicht weniger gewalt weil das
theater hat das funktioniert ja einfach
nicht also wenn die einzige taktik ist
oder ist gewalt wir machen
auslandseinsatz und jetzt ja jetzt
bleiben wir da wir bleiben so lange wie
möglich jetzt gehen wir wieder weg wir
wollen da geht es direkt weiter und
wieder werden alle unterdrückt dann ist
es einfach anscheinend nicht die takte
die am besten funktioniert die frage
wichtig direkt an euch weitergeben was
sagt ihr denn geht frieden ohne waffen
sagt ihr ist das total utopisch oder ist
es realistisch schreibt gerne mal in die
kommentare was sagst du geht treten ohne
waffen ich würde mir wünschen dass es
geht ich wollte noch einen punkt machen
zu prävention und so weiter ich bin da
auch irgendwie total dafür das war wegen
auch nach vorne gegangen dass man auch
über abrüstung stärker reden muss dass
man sich da mehr dafür engagieren muss
und so ich finde wir sind in deutschland
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen in einem
dilemma weil es wurde halt ganz lange
nicht öffentlich über die notwendigkeit
von von militärausgaben und so weiter
ausführlich gesprochen und und leute
wünschen sich irgendwie alle das ist
dass man das nicht muss jetzt ist in
deutschland in deutschland steht total
unter dem druck mehr auch teilweise für
militär auszugeben weil verbündete das
fördern weil die usa das fordern und es
ich finde das weckt in deutschland so
ein bisschen die wahrnehmung dass jetzt
massiv aufgerüstet werden und zu dem
argument wenn wir immer so weitermachen
dann bringen sich irgendwann alle und
als ich meine das ist er jetzt auch
nicht so als hätten wir internationalen
politik die woge konflikt und gewalt
irgendwie exponentiell steigt sondern es
gab initiativen wie die un die gegründet
wurden es gibt diese ganzen formate es
gibt internationale verträge zur
abrüstung und so weiter das passiert ja
alles und ich glaube wir sind irgendwie
alle dafür wie du vorhin gesagt dass ihr
könnt mir da drüben kampf getränken dass
das auch weiterhin passiert die frage
ist halt einfach nur wie gehen wir mit
situationen um wo deutschland verbündete
militärisch sich engagieren soll da
stand sich da beteiligen oder soll
deutschland sich daraus nehmen
moritz sagt nein heraus nehmen also vor
einem jahr lang schon diese idee von
die idee von es gibt und verbund und du
hast das beispiel gemacht mit amerikaner
haben gesagt wir gehen nach afghanistan
dann gab es einen bündnispartner wurde
gesagt gut stehen wir da mithin haben
den plan den wir schon haben dann kommen
abend merkt niemand kennt die kultur
spricht immer die sprache nur du wer es
gibt es gibt verschiedene muslime auch
wer streitet denn jetzt noch 20 jahre
später haben wir das nie verstanden ist
keine gute idee ist da gibt es im fall
von frankreich das heißt das argument
ist im grunde genommen ja wir sind so
eine freundesgruppe und der wurde ja
gesagt wir gehen jetzt in vermögen und
ich denke also muss ich aber wir sind
freunde ja dann mache ich mit und das
reicht nicht als argument arbeit ist ja
nicht die einzigen beispiel ich bin
irgendwie total bereit wenn es darum
geht zu sagen dass in afghanistan
fielen nicht gut gelaufen ist und dass
man da eine größere debatte darüber
hätte haben sollen in deutschland dass
man die im nächsten fall auch auf jeden
fall haben muss dass man die jetzt
wieder haben muss wenn man afghanistan
aufarbeitet wenn man den mali einsatz
potenziellen verlängert und da gibt es
ja jetzt auch schon irgendwie eine
richtung dass man sagt da müssen wir
lieber noch mal drüber nachdenken bin
ich total dafür ich höre ja die ganze
zeit brauchen eine größere debatte das
nehme ich schon mal mit zur kompromiss
runde später ich würde gerne mit euch
noch über realistische alternativen der
bundeswehr sprechen moritz du bist
nämlich dass es gerade schon deutlich
gemacht gegen militärische
auslandseinsätze du würdest das geld
wahrscheinlich eher für eine humanitäre
armee ausgeben wie könnt ihr dann
aussehen was das wäre das eine
humanitäre armee also ich glaube dass
bestimmte sachen gibt die bundeswehr
schon jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr gut kann
und was sie auch ohne werfen weiter tun
könnte so was für medizinische hilfe es
ist wahrscheinlich gibt es
wahrscheinlich recht ist die medizin ist
die bundeswehr ganz gut aufgestellt vor
allem in medizinischer hilfe die dann da
angewandt werden kann wo man nicht in
einem ausgebauten op saal sitzt sondern
an orten wo nicht allzu gute bedingungen
herrschen ich schätze mal dass die oder
ich weiß meine familie ich habe einige
soldat in einer familie organisation das
umdenken bei der armee also dass china
ganz gut hin zu sagen passt auf wir
haben organisationen da sind leute und
das machen wir jetzt straf und jeder
weiß was zu tun ist und dann macht man
das und dann kommt man ans ziel und das
ist wahrscheinlich was was man in sehr
sehr vielen katastrophen schutzgebieten
genau das bräuchte ich bin nicht dafür
zusagen ab morgen sind alle soldatinnen
mit eure waffen ihr seid entlassen geht
nach hause dass es keine
nein ich finde ich finde diese menschen
gaben sehr gute fähigkeiten gelernt
viele kinder anscheinend in die armee
und zu sagen ich möchte leuten helfen
und dann kann man den menschen nutzen
nämlich diese leute ohne waffen anderen
menschen helfen könnten was wir jetzt
machen mit wir schicken keine menschen
oder michigan material bestehen
vielleicht noch mal ein krankenhaus
flugzeug das sollte nicht aufhören aber
vielleicht hören wir auf panzer zu
kaufen und kaufen irgendwas was erstens
danach auch funktioniert und zweitens
ein bisschen sinnvolle ausgaben hat als
jetzt kann ich bin ich jeden abknallen
den ich sehe andreas kannst du dir das
vorstellen dass moritz gerade gesagt hat
durchaus auch eine persönliche
einstellung ist wir können humanitär
viel mehr leisten als militärisch im
auslandseinsatz das habt ihr alle gesagt
wir sind überhaupt nicht dafür
ausgerüstet militärischen verein sterben
dass kann auch nicht unser auftrag sein
meinen auftrag oder meine zielrichtung
war es immer wenn ich persönlich mich
entschieden habe in den auslandseinsatz
zu gehen da in den kosovo und nach
afghanistan war es immer dafür einen
kleinen teil dazu beizutragen dass
menschen in sicherheit leben können und
eben natürlich sollen auch
fluchtursachen bekämpft werden damit das
heißt nicht dass sich keine menschen
hier aufnehmen möchte aber was ich als
erstes machen muss ist eben
fluchtursachen bekämpfen indem ich
sicherheit schaffen im land das die
menschen eben nicht flüchten müssen
sondern sie möchten ihre heimat nicht
verlassen wenn man mit ganz vielen
menschen spricht aus afghanistan das
größte wäre in ihrem land zu bleiben und
einem friedlichen land zu leben und dass
die frage wie ich das erreiche und wenn
ich humanitär eingreifen muss dann gibt
es auch gruppen die dagegen sind und um
das zu unterstützen und zu schützen
brauche ich im militär und wenn ich das
nicht mit panzern mache dann ist das für
mich vollkommen in ordnung dass sich das
mit sanität mache und dass ich das mit
pionieren macher und dort
brückenbau zufahrtswege schaffe wegeplan
ihre flächen plan ihre um dort was hin
zu bauen krankenhäuser hin zu bauen der
infrastruktur aufzubauen und dafür nutze
ich eben das know how auch unter anderem
der bundeswehr dann ist das gut weil ich
glaube nicht dass es irgendein soldat
gibt der geil drauf ist menschen zu
töten
kann ich zumindest nicht matador ist nun
schritt für schritt zurückgegangen ja
ich habe bei fluchtursachen bekämpfen
wir unser allergisch da ich glaube das
natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere
debatte aber ich finde es immer sehr
interessant weil ich glaube sozusagen
über das argument der flucht
ursachenbekämpfung was ja ein valides
ist ja also natürlich möchte auch nicht
dass menschen fliehen müssen kommen wir
aber ganz schnell natürlich auch eine
realpolitische
in realpolitik letzten endes unter
anderem auch der deutschen
bundesregierung und ich frage mich dann
immer ist es denn wirklich dann die
aufgabe der deutschen bundesregierung
fluchtursachen zu bekämpfen und letzten
endes ja immer wieder das haben wir auch
gesehen mit werten der des globalen
norden das mit werten der demokratie und
liebe wird wird innen länder zugehen die
ganz auf ganz anderen kulturellen werten
ja auch beruhen ja also wir
kennen diese diskussion aus den usa dass
viele soldatinnen und soldaten am ende
gesagt haben dem demokratie kann man den
leuten auf den teller legen aber
vielleicht haben sie trotzdem in gewusst
was anderes zu essen oder
beziehungsweise vielleicht sind sie
einfach nicht bereit dafür komplett
amerikanische ideen und vorstellungen zu
übernehmen und ich glaube fluchtursachen
bekämpfen in der deutschen politik
bedeutet vorrangig erstmal deutsche
systeme westliche systeme auf zu stülpen
auf länder des globalen südens und das
haben wir natürlich im wahrhaftig in den
letzten jahren ja auch gesehen und ich
glaube ein mensch in uniform wird immer
ein fremdkörper sein in einer anderen
kultur ist es völlig egal ob das jetzt
in afghanistan ist in mali ist oder in
dem nächsten einsatz woche meinen
menschen uniform wird nie auf augenhöhe
mit der zivilgesellschaft sein können
und menschen uniformen wird niemals
einen zivilisten oder eine zivilistin
davon überzeugen doch in diesem land zu
bleiben da bin ich fest von überzeugt
sei ja ich würde die frage gerne an dich
weiterleiten hast du denn das gefühl
dass der westliche werte afghanistan
übergestülpt werden sollten die nicht
erwünscht waren die westliche welt sind
nicht so komplett er wünsche nach
ganztag
afghanische menschen sind muslime und
die haben ihre eigene wette und die
wurden menschen leben wie sie es früher
gemacht haben auch in der zukunft aber
ich denke unser problem ist jetzt die
afghanischen menschen
kämpfen um ihre rechte auf bildung der
arbeit zu gehen die frauen wohl nicht
die missliche wetter sondern die willen
zur schule gehen so investiert die
arbeiten in der gesellschaft gesehen zu
werden die man mitspracherecht haben
sich politisch engagieren aber die
frauen ab ganze frauenproblem ist nicht
nur die kleidung die hunden sich nicht
in westliche bekleiden die und einfach
was lernen was in der gesellschaft
machen von menschen gehört wenn deshalb
das problem in afghanistan
ich habe also genau das ist der punkt
also vor 20 jahren wurden frauen in
afghanistan unterdrückt und haben wir
gesagt jetzt jetzt maschine werde aber
ein erstmals stehen wir da raus und 20
jahre später werden jetzt wieder frauen
unterdrückt und irgendwie es mal nicht
an bereit zu sagen ja aber vielleicht
war dann der militäreinsatz nicht so
erfolgreich aber trotzdem kann man dann
ja nicht sagen dass die afghanische
bevölkerung das nicht wollte sondern zur
afghanischen bevölkerung gehören ja
nicht wissen ist zu sagen weil ich bin
deutscher in deutschland ich bin
wirklich anmaßen zu sagen glaubt die
aufgaben wollen doch keine armen dass
ich war da nicht das weiß ich nicht also
ich finde es total schwierig darüber zu
diskutieren weil ich glaube wir reden
hier über eine situation die du am
besten kennt die wir aber oder du hast
natürlich auch oft vor ort aus einer
anderen perspektive wenn man nicht für
mich extrem schwer mich hinzustellen und
zu sagen das und das ist es was wir
brauchen die menschen zu helfen in der
situation ja also ich kann gerne jetzt
hier irgendwie ein paar vermeintlich
schlauer dinge über mali sagen aber
letzten endes habe ich keine ahnung weil
ich faktisch natürlich nicht irgendwie
vor ort bin und ich glaube das ist
erstmal das ding also tatsächlich ist
genau der erste schritt den wir machen
müssen ist den dialog zu finden mit
denen menschen die betroffen sind und
das passiert in deutschland einfach zu
selten das passiert auch innerhalb der
bundeswehr zu selten aber ich glaube vor
dass wir größtenteils weiße europäer
sind uns darüber unterhalten was wir tun
können müssen wir im dialog treten mit
wirklichen leuten die sich kulturell
auskennen die von dort sind weil wir tun
jetzt nichts anderes als das was die
bundeswehr seit jahren tut nämlich über
orte zu urteilen und unsere
vorstellungen genau darauf zu stülpen
und es muss natürlich auch sein also
müssen es auch in diesem rahmen
unterhalten aber ich glaube der erste
schritt wäre grundsätzlich näher an den
oder mit den menschen zusammen zu
arbeiten die dann betroffen sind das
waren schon ein paar lösungsansätze da
können wir gleich vertiefen gleich
geht's weiter mit der kompromiss runter
aber vorher möchte ich dir noch eine
letzte frage stellen soll denn du bist
dafür dass deutschland innerhalb
internationaler auslandseinsätze mehr
verantwortung übernehmen sollte ich
würde das gern noch einmal klären was
bedeutet denn mehr verantwortung ich tue
mich schwer damit zu sagen wie wir leben
in deutschland irgendwie in einem
demokratischen system mit
freiheitsrechten und so weiter dass wenn
wir nochmal an den anfang dieses systems
zurückdenken nur existiert weil es eine
militärische antwort gab auf auf ein
autokratisches regime und die
privilegierte situation in der ich
aufgewachsen bin in der viele andere von
uns auch aufgewachsen sind und ich wie
gesagt mit dem ziel zu sagen frieden
ohne waffen da würde ich auf jeden fall
auch zustimmen aber bei uns hat auch
nicht funktioniert und ich versuche das
immer so ein bisschen deshalb zu
erklären um eben auch zu erklären warum
warum sagen wir jetzt in deutschland wir
brauchen eine größere debatte dazu na
also sowas ist der deal mit den
internationalen verbündeten wenn ihr
sagt deutschland sollte sich mehr nur
auf sanitäts leistungen auf irgendwie
logistische unterstützungsleistung frau
einlassen so ich glaube darauf das wird
nicht funktionieren in denen wir die
temp bündnissen und politischen
bündnissen in denen mehr aktuell sind
die nato irgendwie der der nuklearen
schutzschirm unter dem irgendwie
westeuropa ist diese ganzen sachen die
beruhten das ist also sind auch
politische übereinkünfte wo man dann
sagen muss ich werde mir das nicht mehr
wollen dann müssen wir das aufkündigen
dann muss es konsequent sein dann muss
es sein okay deutschland schickt
irgendwie nur noch sanitäterinnen und
sanitäter in un einsätze aber dann kann
man eben auch nicht mehr erwarten dass
japan sich zurücklehnen kann wenn es
irgendwie um russland geht oder oder wie
auch immer eine akute bedrohung in der
östlichen nachbarschaft das ist die
konsequenz davon ich hätte du wirst
einen großen schritt zurückgegangen ja
also ich manchmal sieht man es
wahrscheinlich ihren einsatz für
deutschland ja glücklicherweise nicht
dabei
waren ja und zum anderen würde ich
einfach sagen man muss diese debatte
führen und sich dann hoffentlich auch zu
der erkenntnis kommen dass das was
maschine heutzutage macht und wie sie
aufgebaut ist und was die ziele hat und
sowas deshalb kontraproduktiv ist ich
habe einen kompromissvorschlag von mir
an euch und dem könnt ihr entweder
zustimmen oder er findet ihr nicht gut
und bleibt stehen oder geht das ende des
feldes und danach könnt ihr jeweils auf
eurem fällt euch die köpfe
zusammenstecken und euch einen eigenen
kompromissvorschlag überlegen und den
der anderen seite präsentieren aber
vorher beginne ich mit der ersten frage
von 13 fragen können wir uns darauf
einigen dass wir die bundeswehr aktuell
brauchen ihre zukünftigen aufgaben aber
in einer möglichst breiten
gesellschaftlichen debatte besprochen
und definiert werden müssen also nicht
nur von fall zu fall im bundestag
sondern beispielsweise auch ein gremium
in dem menschen mitten aus der
gesellschaft vertreten sind die mit dem
thema auf unterschiedlichste art und
weise sich schon befasst haben also zum
beispiel menschen wie ihr könnt jetzt
gerne einen schritt auf mich zu gehen
oder stehen bleiben oder zurück gehen du
bist kein staat auf mich zugegangen
rechten kleinen kleinen mini schaut
michael andrews fans verlassen warum
michael ja ich brauche die bundeswehr
nicht mateja du bist du jetzt seinen
schritt ermöglicht zwar ich bin ziemlich
weit nach vorne gekämpft dann auch nicht
so ganz da vorne schäme ich mich so
alleine geführt okay gut dann ist noch
ein bisschen luft für er denn jetzt
könnt ihr euch kompromiss überlegen
dass ich mir auch unterschiedliche
positionen
hilfsorganisationen das regieren könnten
bevor der einsatz was stimmt ja nicht
schwieriges thema am ende sind meine
ganze hat es doch ein bisschen
aufeinander zugegangen ein bisschen luft
ist noch und sentieren idee hat wie wir
diese luft füllen könnten und die gäste
ins kompromiss feld bringen dann schreib
doch mal euren kompromiss in die
kommentare aber er ist gut darin uns
nicht einigen klar habe ich meine wir
sitzen hier kartoffeln
sehr gut dann bin ich gespannt auf eure
kompromissvorschläge und fang wird euch
an mit der grünen seite was sagt er also
unser kompromissvorschlag an euch ist
bundeswehr im auslandseinsatz ja aber
mit einem klaren auftrag mit einer
klaren zielsetzung die humanitär
ausgerichtet ist rein humanitär nicht
als angriffs armee nicht um militärische
und wirtschaftliche interessen
durchzusetzen sondern rein humanitär das
wäre unser angebot und das auch nur nach
einer debatte im bundestag natürlich wo
eben menschen eingeladen werden aus der
breiten bevölkerungsschicht forint alle
gruppen von menschen eingeladen werden
wo ich eben veteranen höhere die aus
einsätzen kommen und ihre erfahrung
präsentieren und wir müssen natürlich
bevölkerungsgruppen einbeziehen die eben
geflüchtet sind zu uns und die daran
teilhaben müssen und wir müssen ganz
wichtig auch dort hinten die deutsche
friedensgesellschaft mit einbeziehen
weil die ideen die die werte sind
grundsätzlich sehr gut wie man die
umsetzen kann darüber muss man
diskutieren
alternative kann es nicht sein wir
schaffen alles ab und dennis frieden das
funktioniert nicht und daher ist unser
kompromissvorschlag am ja auch im
auslandseinsatz humanitäre zwecke bezug
zur bevölkerung dass man darüber eine
große debatte führt und dann mit einer
klaren zielsetzung die eben rein
humanitär ausgerichtete ist kann ich
dann gern zu dem kompromiss
positionieren wenn ihr wollt
also bis zum schritt zur rückkehr zu
gelangen ja ok wieso weil es klingt nach
dem fisch
ehrlich gesagt ich finde das waren da
nicht wichtig diesen debatten chance
eröffnen absolut und ich finde es
allerhöchste zeit ich finde aber
natürlich immer diese bundeswehr unter
rein humanitären zweck ist es gibt ja
auch schon tolle sachen die rein
humanitär sind die im katastrophenschutz
aktiv sind die könnte man jetzt zum
beispiel auch stärken da bin ich nicht
so ganz sicher ob das nicht dann am ende
sagen dass man ein bisschen die katze im
sack kauft und am ende dann doch sehr
sehr viele menschen in uniform hat die
vielleicht doch nicht so ganz humanitär
ausgerichtet sind sondern eben sehr
stattlich idealistisch da jetzt euch was
ist denn euer kompromissvorschlag wir
haben sehr pragmatische kompromisse zum
beispiel dass wir selbstverständlich
mehr abrüsten müssen also das sozusagen
waffenexporte gestoppt werden dass wir
mit internationalen verträgen arbeiten
müssen dass wir zum beispiel mehr
finanzielle mittel in zivilen
friedensdienst stecken müssen das nicht
so eine diskrepanz zwischen
militärischer und ziviler kräfte der
derzeit existiert das
zivilgesellschaftliche
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement ob
das in der seenotrettung ist in der
evakuierung in an unterschiedlichen
formen unterstützt werden muss
allerdings ohne sich der verantwortung
zu entziehen und das wir vor allem dafür
sorgen müssen dass und da glaube ich
sind wird es nicht ganz einig dass die
bundeswehr oder ein bundeswehreinsatz am
ende das allerletzte mittel wäre wenn
genau diese ganzen zivilen und
militärischen mittel komplett
ausgeschöpft sind so ihr habt den
kompromissvorschlag von dem gelben feld
gehört habt ihr interesse daran einen
schritt auf das andere feld zu gehen ja
also ich würde mich nur fragen was wir
dann mit unseren bündnispartnern machen
weil ich glaube
na ja das muss man also ich meine
letzten endes ist doch also jetzt mal
utopisch gedacht ja oder idealistisch
gedacht ist es doch genau das gleiche
man sagt man geht in die zivile
friedensverhandlungen und media zwischen
konfliktparteien ja wir sind hier auch
in wahnsinnigen ideen unterwegs aber man
könnte ja auch da ja genauso
verhandlungen führen die die zu einer
versöhnung zu hören bekommen und die
sozusagen auch zu kompromissen schön wie
hier andreas gt der innenstadt so oder
bleibt er stehen mir kam gerad die idee
dazu was ihr alle drei gesagt habt eine
über führenden also die bundesliga
führen utopisch gedacht einfach mal in
eine
zivilgesellschaft um die aufgaben die
sie einfach auch gut können dort
auszuführen dass ich bin jetzt auch im
technischen hilfswerk
daher kann ich mir das durchaus
vorstellen dass die aufgaben auch in dem
rahmen durchzuführen aber ich würde mich
denn noch immer unsicher fühlen in ein
bürgerkriegsland oder in ein land wo
eben auch gewalt herrscht ohne waffen zu
gehen um mich selbst zu verteidigen oder
eben andere schutzbedürftige personen zu
verteidigen da würde ich mich echt
schlecht mitfühlen wo wir uns auf einen
können wir also bewarb nicht bewaffnete
des thw angenommen denn das bundeswehr
die bundeswehr nennt deswegen bei nicht
worden damit werden lassen wie das
ist unser kompromiss
davon dass wir gar nicht so weit
auseinander waren dass ich für mich
mitgenommen habe was so die zivile seite
eigentlich möchte mehr humanitäres
engagement und weniger militärisches und
da bin ich voll bei hier grundsätzlich
glaube ich sollten wir öfter solche
gespräche schön
auch vielleicht in zukunft miteinander
und das wäre sicherlich sehr produktiv
und vielleicht machen wir dann in der
zukunft auch dinge besser aber was ich
auf jeden fall noch mal gemerkt dass es
keine komplett neue erkenntnis aber wie
schlimm ist wenn diese debatten in der
öffentlichkeit entweder unter teppich
gekehrt werden oder unehrlich geführt
werden also wenn es eben genau um solche
dinge geht wie was macht die bundeswehr
eigentlich in mali was war zu welchem
zeitpunkt des afghanistan-einsatzes
welches ziel warum sind wir aber wir
haben auch gesprochen über die
demokratische basis dafür und da es ist
auf jeden fall nicht nicht genug neben
gibt es nicht weil ich es einfach nur
ach ja es geht jetzt wieder um grund die
sich letztes kind und frauen macht damit
auch also sonst in die anderen seite so
einfach zu sagen ja da sind interessen
über die wird nicht gesprochen und das
sind irgendwelche wirtschaftlichen und
die sind ist natürlich der vorwurf lässt
sich leicht erheben wenn wenn man halt
so öffentliche statements von der
politik hat wie super afghanistan war
als erfolgreich man merkt er hatte beide
auf beiden seiten eigentlich viele
kompromissvorschläge die heute gefallen
sind und deswegen danke ich euch erstmal
dass wir bis zu diesem punkt diskutiert
haben danke euch
was wir glaube ich alle außer diskussion
mitnehmen können das dass wir mehr über
dieses thema sprechen müssen in einer
gesellschaft untereinander in unseren
freundeskreisen und wenn ihr noch
weitere spannende diskussion sehen wollt
dann lasst auch gerne ein abo für diesen
kanal da hier oben könnt ihr ein
weiteres video von 13 fragen sehen und
hier unten ein weiteres video zum thema